a lone figure descending from one of the
last flights out britain's man in kabul
forced to return home and move his
embassy to another country
we've had to leave afghanistan for now
and the embassy will operate from qatar
for the time being
but we'll continue to stand by the
people of afghanistan
working on humanitarian diplomatic and
security work
and above all bringing to the uk
afghans and british nationals who still
need our support
it's 20 years since british forces
started fighting in afghanistan it cost
457 british lives and billions of pounds
as the last soldiers to serve there
returned home leaving the taliban back
in charge the prime minister insisted
their comrade sacrifice had not been
futile let me speak directly to the
families and loved ones
of those british troops
who gave their all
your suffering
and your hardship were not in vain
it was no accident that there's been no
terrorist attack launched against
britain or any other western country
from afghanistan in the last 20 years
but terrorists not al qaeda but isis k
were planning action in kabul today
suicide bombers in a vehicle heading for
the airport destroyed in a drone attack
say the us
averting a repeat of friday's attack
that killed 13 americans
their commander-in-chief stood in
respect for the dead as their remains
were brought home
a moment to reflect on what has been a
disastrous and tragic fortnight
the next 48 hours remain highly
dangerous for the americans as they race
to end their withdrawal
and they start warning from neighboring
pakistan today that the west can't walk
away from afghanistan without the risk
of return to the darkest moments of two
decades ago
there was a breakdown of law and order
there was a breakdown of security uh
there were international terrorists who
took root uh there was an economic
crisis there was a governance problem
and at the end of the day there was 9
11.
britain and america can pull out of
afghanistan but that won't end the
multiple threats it could pose
it may be the end of one era but another
equally uncertain one may be only just
beginning
dominic waghorn sky news